I pulled up a tweet from ilhan Omar from
earlier today from I guess this was from
about noon today and it says I'll read
it for you it says representation
matters we we didn't come to Congress to
be silent we came to Congress to be a
voice for families who are displaced in
refugee camps and those Seeking Justice
around the world so where were you when
MTG was tripped of all our committees
good question show me one of these
people who are so upset right now who
are screaming who are crying who are are
losing their minds
representation matters we didn't come to
Congress to be silent we came to
Congress to be a voice for families who
are displaced in refugee camps and those
Seeking Justice around the world because
that's what this child's Survivor of War
would have wanted no she came to
Congress to represent her Minnesota
District that's my point first of all
when she says the whole thing we didn't
come to come who's we it's it's ilhan
whose we didn't come to Congress who are
you talking about
co-conspirators like ilhan it's you
who's talking about her brother maybe
maybe and also you made her husband your
husband you make a good point to him
that you know ilhan you didn't go to
Congress to to be a voice for refugees
around the world you went there to
represent the people of Minnesota in
that one small part of Minnesota but not
really I mean she's telling you what she
came to Congress for right
in the world I mean I think she is being
honest
you have to understand and her District
should now be like oh interesting
interesting that's who you are your
constituents what you've just identified
though is a trend line that connects the
the Chinese spy story the spyballoon
story to this where we have to
understand that the United States
government or the GAE or whatever you
want to call it the globalist American
Empire is is run throughout with foreign
interests that we've got foreign
interest controlling so much of our
government we've got so much influence
from wealthy foreign governments whether
it be Iran whether it be China whether
it be Qatar that our whether it be Saudi
Arabia et cetera that are pushing their
interests through these members of
Congress because you're allowed to raise
money from anywhere in the country right
you can't you don't just have to raise
money from your own District so you're
representing not only the people who
vote for you but the people who fund
your campaign do like Saudi princes fund
packs that fund camp that fund
politicians probably what do you think
my guess is yes legally a Saudi Prince
is not legally allowed to give 100
million dollars to a candidate
no American citizen could do that yeah
or even a million bucks what I always
say to the campaign Finance reform like
the people who spurg out on that
um and you find a lot of like a lot of
people on the left really spur guys oh
we need to have like this law and that
law and it's the money's going to get
there the money's going to get there
either way right the money is always
going to find a way to get into these
areas and so this is a fundamental flaw
with the system that if you've got more
money
not always but you know if you're
looking at a race like Congress where
you know how many people can name their
Congressman or remember Congress you
know that you know you're going to say
well I've seen that guy's name a bunch I
guess I'll vote for him or hey this guy
seems crazy because you've got a
well-funded uh smear campaign against
them
and say oh well I can't vote for that
guy because that's not well that's
that's the Jewish space lasers lady I
couldn't vote for her but why Alexandria
ocasio-cortez told me that she's the
Jewish space laser person now
fortunately Margaret Taylor Green's in a
district where I don't think they're
going to be listening to AOC very much
but Lauren bobert isn't and a
well-funded opponent could come in
against Lauren bobert very easily you
saw this almost happen right where I
don't think people realized how close
she came something like 500 votes yeah
and so this is always going to be a
problem with the American model of
government because of the representative
the House of Representatives can be
bought off or bribed by corporate people
that want to give their laws so the
representatives passed their laws into
the Senate if there were no
Representatives if this was all like
direct representation where you gotta
you'd have to bribe 700 000 of us if you
want our district to vote a certain way
not going to happen not not likely not
as likely as one person uh they would
still pay lawyers to pass laws into the
Senate so it's either like the richest
people are always going to dominate
politics or the most intelligent and
able to write laws will could possibly I
could see like a well-educated populace
could
take become more valuable than the
monetary system but the webs is the
people that are rich will buy the
intelligent people off the lawyers and
stuff and they'll find that smartest
lawyers to write the best laws for them
and then it becomes like a bidding war I
I
there's a reason that when we talk about
Davos so Davos just ended and this is
sort of the meeting of the globalist
American Empire where they where they
sit and sort of cackle around about what
they're going to be doing and there's an
interesting take on that because I think
people realize that it's it's a it's
tough to put a specific word to it but
we understand that when you see the AOC
performative art and the theater from
Rashida Talib we realize that these
aren't the actual people that are making
the decisions these aren't the people
that are actually ruling over us these
aren't the people that are setting the
agenda and you're seeing that more and
more even in the Biden Administration as
they're removing long-time allies and uh
confidants and advisors like Ron Clane
and then getting in people like Jeff
zenz who is a Bain Capital uniparty guy
the same way that he's sort of like you
know the Democrat side of Bain the way
that Romney was the Republican side of
Bain but they're really the same company
right it's a great it's actually a
perfect example for us to understand
this that this is how the uni party
works so they're able to get their
people in
and even the bite Administration itself
nobody nobody sits there and talks about
the incredible Biden campaign and the
Mastery of the uh you know this who was
Biden's campaign manager
Obama's campaign managers went on to
have some of the most successful media
careers they run some of the most
successful podcasts on the left right
now with the Biden campaign who did they
launch there's nothing there's
absolutely because people understand
that that was predominantly the power
structure deciding to pluck him up and
bring him in as president and we call
this the globalist American they they
said stay alive Joe Biden all we need is
your corporeal form that's right that
was it that was a news article what was
it Atlantic they wrote there's something
like that yeah stay alive Joe Biden let
me see if I can find this but I think I
think what we're seeing now though and
this is why to go back to 101
Constitution Atlantic there you go the
Atlantic same thing right and what what
date did that come out this is uh
March 24th 2020. Democrats
Democrats little from the front runner
Beyond his corporeal presence
that's great they were right and that's
pretty much all right saying you will
not have a president you will have a a a
figurehead in an old retiree a vessel
yeah and that's you need someone to sit
in the chair but he's not going to
really do it but I think I think what
we're seeing right now with the
classified documents coming out with
Hunter Biden very stupidly admitting
that the laptop was his oh that was
amazing threatening to fire lawsuit file
lawsuits against those of us that were
that were spreading it in 20 which
please do by the way please sue me
Hunter Biden I'd I'd be more than happy
to get Discovery in a lawsuit with
Hunter Biden so please Hunter Biden have
your lawyers contact my lawyers sue me
Sue me right now I figured out uh
Biden's campaign manager was Greg
Schultz who's that what's he up to now
you see what I mean it breaks exactly my
point
it's kind of the same way that like it
when we were talking about the current
thing earlier that during in if you
weren't old enough to remember the sort
of post-911 era we were you know
suddenly we became uh experts in the
Middle East and you know you had to know
you know who's the best prime minister
for Afghanistan is it a shrief ghani or
is it is it Karzai uh who should be the
next leader of Iraq and we must topple
Saddam Hussein because Saddam Hussein is
the you know the greatest threat to
world uh world peace right now the same
way you've got people talking about
toppling Iran you know tomorrow but here
we are a couple what two decades later
and nobody talks about Iraq anymore we
know Taliban the Taliban retook
Afghanistan nobody even mentions them
because you're not told to mention them
I thought that the other day I was like
all these people that are like hey we
want Russians out of Ukraine it is not
ripe for a country to invade a smaller
foreign country where were they when
they were talking about pulling our
troops out of Iraq like when the
Americans we're still invading Iraq
Libya at least we still have troops here
in Syria right now so get them out get
them out speak up about it that that's
why I hate to bring it up again but when
when Hassan did his response to me and
he's like the military industrial
complex is bad but we should be in
Ukraine it's like what do you think that
is what do you think all of this has
always been but that's an excellent
point Ian that all these people are like
Russia what did Kamala Harris say Russia
as a big country and they invaded a
little country and that's why it's bad
it's like oh well the United States is a
big country and we invaded a couple
little guys was that bad I will actually
give Kamala Harris credit on that
because for a little bit because I try
to I try to find things that I like
about the other side and and and it
makes it harder that way right um You
have to be easy to just rip on them but
she actually does have a point that you
don't really hear that when people are
talking about the Strategic military
calculus of we're going to send more
tanks okay but how many tanks well like
15. okay well how many tanks does Russia
have they have 1200 right so what are
your 50 what are 15 and zelinski says
this all the time he said it on in an
interview with Trey angst at Fox News
today that he said well you're going to
send 15 tanks they have thousands of
Tanks what difference is this really
going to make to us are you going to
send f-16s but then if you send f-16s
who's going to fly them how are you
going to train someone what are the
logistics for that was the maintenance
for that and then keep in mind they say
okay we'll build a maintenance facility
yeah we'll guess what the next cruise
missile is going to fly into right you
don't take out all the tanks just take
out the maintenance facility we've been
talking about the complex the collapse
of complex systems well when you're in
Wartime you just amplify that by about a
hundred imagine you know you can't find
the right lug nut because oh wait uh
American tanks use the conventional
system but European tanks use the metric
system right so you're where you're
going to find the right pieces for a
leopard that fit in Abrams etc etc all
of these issues that come into play
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time